we're approaching the end of the year
and for many that means work is winding
down and we get to go home and hang out
with family and friends for the holidays
it also gives us time to play a bunch of
video games here's what's coming to
Playstation Plus this month and some
recommendations for games to play with
your family and friends over the
holidays
[Music]
before we jump into what's coming to the
game and Classics catalog this month a
quick reminder that you can still grab
December's monthly games they're
available until January 2nd if you're a
PlayStation Plus essential extra or
premium Member First up is Mass Effect
legendary edition for PlayStation 4. the
remaster of the iconic Mass Effect
Trilogy as Commander Shepard assemble
your team and defend the Galaxy against
Reapers which are conspiring to bring
about the extinction of all organic life
legendary edition features Mass Effect 1
2 and 3 and over 40 pieces of DLC from
armor and weapons packs to MIDI single
player stories like layer of the Shadow
broker and the Beloved Citadel DLC next
up is divine knockout Founders Edition
for PlayStation 4 and PlayStation 5
which launched straight onto PlayStation
Plus earlier this month play as one of
10 playable gods including mimir and
Thor as you battle to boot enemies out
of the Arena Founders Edition includes
bonus content for the game as well as a
character skin in Smite your final
monthly game for December is bio mutant
for PlayStation 4 and Playstation 5. a
post-apocalyptic game where you can mix
all manner of combat styles from martial
arts to guns and add in some mutant
abilities to boot if you're a
PlayStation Plus extra or premium member
you have access to the game catalog and
there are a number of great games
joining this model it's time to step
back into the ring with WWE 2k22 with
new controls the in-ring action has
never felt better and in the 2K showcase
mode you can relive iconic moments from
Rey Mysterio's career build your
All-Star roster in my faction and become
a WWE general manager in my GM WWE 2k22
will be available from January 3rd to
March 13th and when you're done
wrestling hope county is waiting for you
in Far Cry 5 as a sheriff's deputy it's
up to you to take on Joseph's seed
leader of the Doomsday called Eden's
gate and rid Montana of his influence
team up with a friend in Co-op or
recruit and in-game pal like
cheeseburger the bear if you want to
spend more time in Hope County then
you're in luck Far Cry New Dawn is also
joining game catalog this Standalone
spin-off is set in Hope County's 17
years after a nuclear event wrecked the
whole place it's not exactly the murky
post-apocalypse you might expect as the
nuclear fallout has created a luscious
Super Bloom creating a wacky and
colorful environment to explore but if
you fancy going back to the basics
somewhat then give Far Cry Primal a shot
Primal takes you back to the Stone Age
where the beasts that walk the earth can
give you just as much trouble as a rival
tribe craft Spears clubs and arrows and
tame creatures like saber-toothed tigers
to help you face off any threats as you
explore looking for a fantasy world to
get lost in then take on the Dual role
of Gondor Ranger Italian and elf wraith
Keller brimbor in Middle Earth Shadow of
Mordor and its sequel shadow of War
explore the wastes of Mordor and get
revenge for the death of your family by
tearing through the ranks of Orcs using
the game's Dynamic Nemesis system but if
you're sick of being a good guy try out
Evil Genius 2 become a criminal
mastermind and build out your lair with
enough nefarious traps and minions to
keep the forces of Justice at Bay Evil
Genius 2 is full of heavy knots to
Classic spy films and it's funny to boot
now it's time for me to get on my Yakuza
soapbox three more games are joining the
game catalog meaning there's really no
excuse not to give the Fantastic
franchise a go Yakuza 6 the song of life
is the final game with series
protagonist Kazama Kiryu at the helm so
you can now experience his entire Saga
and one spot Yakuza like a dragon
switches things up drastically and is a
great game to play if you want to dip
your toe into Yakuza without committing
to the whole series you play as Ichiban
a Yakuza grunt sent to prison for a
murder he didn't commit after he's freed
and sent back into a world and a yak is
a family that has moved on without him
Yakuza games are usually Brawlers but
like a dragon switches things on its
head and it's turn base the melodrama
and heart at the core of Yakuza games is
still there so like a dragon is a
perfect jumping off point judgment a yak
is a spin-off also joins the catalog
instead of playing as a member of the
Yakuza you play as detective takayuki
yugami who's working to get to the
bottom of a series of murders in Tokyo I
am hopping off my Yakuza soapbox now
thank me later next up is Mortal shell
as the foundling you take on the rotten
world of fall Grim in sort of a spirit
form enemies can easily kill you in this
form so it's up to you to find find a
mortal shell so you can square off
against them the shells allow for a lot
of variety and gameplay and if you're a
fan of from soft Souls games this is
worth a try for more family-friendly
offerings take an underwater adventure
with Finn Jake and all your Adventure
Time Pals and Adventure Time pirates of
the encouridion or stop fiendish aliens
in Ben 10 power trip if a dinosaur
adventure is more your thing
gigantosaurus the game is the one for
you looking to exercise your brain
muscles The Pedestrian is a quirky take
on a puzzle platformer where you move
road signs around to create a path
through the environment but if you fancy
a deep RPG to sink some hours into check
out pillars of Eternity 2 deadfire
Ultimate Edition chase a rogue God
across the unexplored land and chart
your own adventure in an RPG built on
DND gameplay also joining the game
catalog this month are worms wmd and the
escapists 2 from 1817 worms wmd Remains
the experience of classic worms games
but has a Fresh coat of paint and some
new mechanics to really up the Mayhem
carefully plot and execute your escape
from prison in The Escapist 2 where how
you escape is up to you if you're a
PlayStation Plus premium member you also
have access to the classics game catalog
full of games from previous PlayStation
Generations this month it's time to put
the pedal to the metal as Ridge Racer 2
joins the catalog or you can hit the
tables in pinball Heroes and speaking of
Heroes when a haunting Vision disturbs
Abe's retirement it's up to him to
discover the secret of the Soul storm
brew and save the trap muticons in odd
World Abe's Exodus if you missed ninja
Theory's cult classic Heavenly sword
which stars Andy Circus it's also
available to stream in the classics
catalog
if you've got some down time to spend
with friends and family this winter then
what better way to bond than to play
some video games together here's my pick
of games from the game catalog that are
perfect to play together overcook 2 has
the potential to make your friendship
stronger or ruin them all together you
work as chefs preparing a series of
meals but one person can't do everything
themselves so you gotta work together to
get those orders out it's a lot of
chaotic fun with simple controls that
everyone can handle in a similar vein
moving out is full of Mayhem in Fun For
All of the family as a Furniture
Arrangement and relocation technician
it's up to you and your pals to help
move furniture from one place to another
but no one said you had to be careful
about it nidhog is simple to learn and
difficult to master with minimal inputs
and frantic one-on-one action this
fencing game will have everyone playing
and watching yelling at the screen in no
time the sequel is also on game catalog
too it might be a little cold to hit the
links in this weather but that doesn't
mean that golf is off the table
completely with everybody's golf you and
three others can face off on a number of
colorful and quirky courses if you fancy
something a little more story driven
definitely give Brothers A Tale of Two
Sons ago you can either play alone or
with one other person controlling the
brothers as they search for a cure for
their father's illness the game tells a
beautiful story set against a colorful
backdrop inspired by Nordic myths be
warned though it can get a little
emotional but at least you can Bond over
it with whoever you're playing with what
are you going to be playing on
PlayStation Plus this month let us know
and make sure to shout out your hidden
gems below you can find me on Twitter at
Devonte Chisholm and I'll see you next
month for your January games
[Music]
foreign
[Music]